j'accueille christophe rocancourt
[Musique]
quelle a été identique et que vous avez
préféré prendre à calais
quelle identité avez-vous gardé le plus
longtemps 3 clair quelle identité était
la plus difficile à porter 3faire quelle
identité était vraiment une mauvaise
idée
rockefeller quelle identité vous
ressembler le plus con tu vas être
surpris rancourt
c'est à paris que tout le monde en a
parlé à retrouver christophe rault
concours l'homme nous a rejoints devant
sa librairie préférée l'une des plus
réputés de la capitale
j'aime les livres
à 44 ans il semblerait que l'ancien
usurpateur d'identité se soit trouvé une
nouvelle vie amateur d'art doit l'eau et
la gueule après avoir passé plus de 12
ans en prison christophe rocancourt
entend bien ne pas sombrer dans
l'anonymat et va maintenant se lancer
dans le cinéma
presque par facilité franchement
orientée dans la carrière d'acteur
parce qu'on peut prendre du fric et
facilement comme je vais faire dans la
vie normale
puis c'est bien ça me permet de m'évader
après dix années vécues sous de fausses
identités
nul besoin de demander à christophe s'il
sait jouer la comédie
jean yves liénard qui est mon avocat
d'ailleurs lui aussi
voilà
et j'avais très envie de travailler avec
un stop parce que le personnage c
quelqu'un de très intéressant
et je pense qu'ils
qu'ils aient une certaine fascination
sur sur le public
les gens ont envie de le découvrir les
gens ont envie de le voir les gens ont
envie de l'entendre
c'est un petit peu le
le départ de mon projet christophe
rocancourt aura le rôle d'un magistrat
dans un film qui retrace sa vie
le monde judiciaire colle à la peau de
christophe même si aujourd'hui il se dit
repenti nous avons maintenant rendez
vous avec l'un de ses amis christian lui
a fondé ggm fondateur du j'espère
l'homme de mitterrand 13 ans décoré de
la légion d'honneur
new line fameux look
tu as bien
donc voilà
l'intégrité on aime on n'aime pas en
impression
mais on peut pas a priori décider que
tel mais bon
vais pas
ça n'a pas de sens yonne
pas sûr
confiance qu'à preuve du contraire
christophe rocancourt a imprimé son nom
dans l'histoire du grand banditisme se
sont faits de bois
décrié par certains chez d'autres il
suscite encore la fascination chez les
survivants après ce qu'il a fait c'est
magnifique
comme un
on va dire spaggiari
sa haine ni violence
bizarre je me considère comme un
même mieux car voyous en col blanc
merci d
vous voulez
c'est un vrai sentiment le tableau de
famille ne serait pas complet sans une
visite chez l'avocat de christophe des
prix qui vous rappellent dans les deux
minutes sur le portable je suis
boulevard raspail arnaqueurs écrivain et
désormais acteur christophe à des droits
qu'il se doit de faire défendre par un
avocat qui ne manque pas d'humour ou à
quelqu'un qui vit son moment ci dit la
vérité ce resto pop en course est
question d'amour d'assedic c'est ce
qu'on appelle un ana correct il pourrait
bien qu elle aille pays pourrait vivre
dans un monastère
il ya besoin de rien lui sur 1000 euros
de temps en temps mais pas plus que ça
enfin je veux dire faut que ce soit
vraiment de temps en temps mais j'ai dû
fermer les comptes pour le mois oui oui
non tatami trois mois l'état qui est un
collector j'ai fait des écoliers a
besoin d'un petit procès de temps en
temps pour que la graine aline remontée
que la vie lui semble un peu
désirable mais sinon voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui a besoin de peu qui vit de
plus qui n'est pas celui qu'on croit
voilà
il avait un sympathique et les pas du
tout entre cynisme et sincérité
où se trouve la vérité christophe seul
semble la détenir mais ne veut pas la
partager
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
christophe rocancourt bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde a parlé alors
christ vous est né le 16 juillet 1967 à
honfleur
votre père daniel était maçon alcoolique
aussi oui votre mère annick étaient
prostituées
vous dites je viens du ruisseau c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire ouais alors vous
raconter qu'à l'âge de 5 ans votre mère
vous abandonne dans une voiture et vous
sectionne l'auriculaire en claquant la
porte
oui le fait pas exprès elle ferme la
porte et ouais ok ne doit pas 8 elle est
partie sans se retourner sur toute la
soirée fut dur ouais j'avais gardé tous
à une haine qui motivera vos aventures
futur pie noël à vous pour l' aventure
mais pas donner un désir de revanche
sans doute inconsciemment nom vous dit
quand on est pro les terres on ne pense
pas avoir de valeur c'est le complexe du
pauvre les vrais courageux sont ceux qui
se lèvent tous les matins ce qu'est
ouais ouais tout à fait vous avez 5 ans
qu'on veut tenir vous abandonne s'est
recueillie par votre grand mère
paternelle mais déjà vous avez de
mauvaises fréquentations et à l'âge de
10 ans vous est confié à l'assistance
publique
quel endroit saint germain village à 15
ans après de multiples fugue vous partez
à paris et c'est là que vous rencontrez
gilles dit gigi un avocat vous dit
j'étais son animal de compagnie ouais
c'est quelqu'un que j'avais une démarche
mondaine chose que je comprenais pas
mais qu'avec quelqu'un dit quelque chose
de très humain
j'ai appris beaucoup et je le remercie
tout à fait il vous aimez bien oui
j'aimais bien aussi
il vous a ouvert les portes de paris oui
castex
et la princesse beauvau crâne de ben ali
est parti pour la bombe
c'est là que vous commencez dans
l'arnaqué donc extorsion de fonds
chèques sans provision falsification
d'actes notariés trafic de fausse
monnaie cambriolage
vous allez en prison ouais cinq fois
exact très jeune mais commence très
jeune et c'est pour pas retourner en
prison une sixième fois que vous prenez
la fuite pour los angeles
vous arrivez en 1991 aigrettes
alors là vous repérer très vite le point
de rencontre des français le café
maurice café moorish c'est là que les
choses commencent très sympa un mec très
bien rires maurice a saoulé 3 c'est un
super mec là vous habitez bel air oui on
aime bien les beaux quartiers
c'est mieux bédarrides un ton au dessus
ouais vous fréquentez mickey rourke un
mickey je suis le plus que fréquente et
je vécu trois ans et quick d'amitié avec
mais qui ont fréquenté aussi jean claude
van damme
ouais john mec sympathique radins com
une pince mais ça avait dit ne pas s'en
empêcher il ya des gens comme ça qui
pensent qu'il faut mais ils sont durs ça
arrive alors la los angeles fait passer
pour le fils de dino de laurentiis et je
rencontre la fille du no1 à l'hôtel à
new york car la ligue 1
je ne suis pas toujours bien conscience
qui veut dire que tient votre soeur est
arrivé j aborde j'ai pu voter
j'ai pris les devants j'ai appelé dans
la chambre puis bah c'est marrant on a
le même nom donc je dis c'est l'histoire
d'un fils de sophia loren aussi sympa y
avait du monde au balcon
ouais fait passer pour un champion de
boxe oui oui justifie un petit peu chez
café maurice
côté financier un champion de boxe qui
veut revenir en plus voilà on apprend
les revenus
on les a même mis ko un producteur de
films aussi
oui bah on devait faire un film avec
micky donc voilà donc vous en carnet
tout un tas de e et le personnage aux
états unis sans problème finalement en
tant qu'acteur on n'en avait pas de
caméra c'est tout moi c'est tout sympa
oui c'est un boulot d'acteur et c'est
vous qui a inventé le scénario ça c'est
ça qui est bien c'est ça qui est dur
mais on peut le faire en temps réel
alors à ce moment là vous faites un
enfant à une playmate qui a quitté la
compagne de steven seagal l'enfant
s'appelle the l'enfant va bien
l'enfant va bien il est bon bon il a
besoin hacker polnareff a renaat si on
veut on va à las vegas je crois qu'à
l'époque je perds 150 mille dollars
paulo est à côté bon il ya des choses
une minime on donne voilà l'histoire se
fait comme ça mais bruit il n'y a pas
une arnaque dans le centre c'est juste
moi j'ai toujours assumé des indiens à
qui je dis oui mais ouais ouais pareil
polnareff grand grand très grand
musicien mais grand con il est il écrit
il ya des gens comme ça en fait on peut
dire ça de moi et je l'assumerai mais
c'est un mec est pathologiquement qu'on
y laisse il faut juste qu'ils jouent du
piano il faut pas qu'il fasse autre
chose
en fait vous l'avez pas arnaquer paul
marie blanc les juges n'ont pas
remboursé ce qu'on a joué au poker
ensemble dégage je crois que le grande
souffrance de paul daraîche et ne pas
être connu aux états unis ce qui était
mon inverse a connu la pire c'est ça qui
rend encore plus plus dur son moulin
alors après vous quittez neuf centres
jeunesse pour new york là où fait passer
pour des héritiers rockefeller
oui on prend les hélicoptères on va dans
le même temps ça nous a plu mais là
c'est le bon moment c'est new york ville
extraordinaire et au canada vous fait
passer pour michael van oven le pilote
de formule 1 sur les ferrari ça c'est
sympa
se retrouvent rencontre un client à
l'époque donc voilà en cabale ans je
suis déjà en cavale
justement à force de jouer au chat et la
souris avec la police
ça se termine un jour vient la trappe en
2000 vous faites serré 50 tôle
ouais et puis pas n'importe où non c'est
perry ancien le plus dur le iceberg usb
je fais atlanta georgia très durs haute
sécurité donc pas sympa quoi ouais rien
à voir avec avec la france de l'america
les violences brutales en france est
encore un petit peu d'humain c'est vrai
alors là pour votre défense vous dites
j'ai jamais forcer personne à croire au
personnage que j'incarne mais voilà la
connerie n'a pas de prix et j'avais dit
une fois dans 6 ème minute lorsqu on
avait fait un interview j'ai su tout le
monde de prendre votre cravate et que
vous me l'a prêté après que vous la
rampe à je vous ai menti mais je vous ai
pas volées
ouais il ya quelque chose d assez
miraculeux dans l'histoire c'est à dire
que lorsqu'on vous donne si on vous
donne mille euros on peut dire
effectivement il peut y avoir une
arnaque
et quand on joue sur 2 103 101 millions
quelqu'un qu'ils amènent 300000 euros en
cash ou a mis en cage il ya quelque
chose d'illégal dans la base eux ont
fait un chèque on dit voilà non mais
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais une victime lors
de mon procès ce masque assez troublant
avait fait douze ans de prison dans ma
main ouais c'était un mauvais mauvaise
étudiants avaient pas compris la leçon
très vite un essai en prison vous prenez
conscience de votre notoriété aux états
unis nbc le new york times vanity fair
vous êtes une star aux etats-unis a
sombré à l'américa mg et l'histoire
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui m'a aidé dans
mon jugement parce que oui sinon
j'aurais pris 500 alors beaucoup plus
avions ce qu'on aurait pris un par 5
voix là j'aurais pris soin s'entendre et
mais j'avais le public américain ok mais
l'histoire
donc j'ai pas subi
que ce soit les médias c'était toujours
des titres le play boy s'était toujours
c'était sympathique
ouais donc il ya une bonne ambiance
vanity fair on avait fait 14 pages la
france d'avant vous percutez beaucoup
plus tard c'est la mairie qui me
découvre justement vous commencé à
écrire moi christophe rocancourt
orphelin playboy et tolar donc aux états
unis en prison et c'est lorsque vous
arrivez en france après votre libération
en 2005 qu'on prend conscience de ce que
vous aide qui vous est alors que les
états unis faisaient déjà extrêmement
connue oui je suis la première page du
nord alors là thomas langmann vaut
porter votre vie à l'écran c'est notre
pote thomas thomas c'est mon pote c'est
quelqu'un qui vient me voir en prison et
c'est pas le producteur c'est pas le
fise octobre berry c'est l'homme qui est
intéressant 20 bat mon rapport avec lui
ce n'est pas un rapport de nos
producteurs ça rapporte amis venaient me
voir en prison un camp lorsque sort
prison c'est lui qui m'aident un qui est
vraiment au cas une vraie amitié c'est
quelqu'un qui est profond à mon sens
qu'elle devrait souffrance et qui
profonde a ensuite fait un enfant à une
miss france sonia rolland
oui l'enfant va bien elle est magnifique
elle est superbe c'est mon grand amour
voilà mais sonia c'est un peu plus
compliqué s'il ya des êtres qu aurait
jamais dû et rançon mais bon vous savez
tout le monde a le droit d' voilà vous
savez des histoires de ses passes et pas
à mon sens c'est pas très important ce
qu'a pourtant c'était ce quelles ont été
les réactions de votre entourage à ce
moment là parce qu'ils marron même
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle ait jamais eu
d'animosité
que ce soit dans la rue que sa raison
que ce soit les banlieues et que ce soit
le rap qui a chanté sur moi mais moi
j'ai un rapport humain avec les gens
donc ils m'ont rendu très bien les gens
j'ai jamais eu 2 1
je suis chanceuse coup votre père était
déjà mort à l'époque oui mon père mort
quand je rentre
aux etats unis c'est assez drôle comme
par hasard vous lui portez respect
quatre à cinq fois par mois les agents
revient il ya trois jours
vous avez toujours sur la tombe de votre
père est je trouve quelque chose de ce
post qui a des valeurs qu'on doit garder
je pense qu'ils nomment aurait rigolé de
voir ce que je suis devenu vrai et ça
j'en suis content or votre mère vous lui
parlez plus en revanche si jamais
reparlé moi je crois que dieu nous
enlèvera ne parlera pas est toujours
vivante
oui tout à fait vous lui parlez pas non
je n'ai aucune animosité du le respect
du feu de gamins qui m'apportez vie mais
ça s'arrête là ouais avec les médias
donc quelles ont été vos relations à
l'époque de bonnes relations
ouais je sois avec denisot que mes deux
mesures
ouais toujours j'ai j'ai pas j'ai jamais
de laisser je me suis jamais laissé
porter moi je fais mes choix match
quelqu'un qui prend ses convictions et
ses choix
si je suis là c'est que j'ai envie
d'être là mais je dis pas oui à tout
supposerait dominique médias ça vous a
rapporté de l'argent
j'ai vendu beaucoup quand même quelqu'un
qui voilà enfin la playboy taulard s'est
vendu à 150 mille vies mais vit 200000
s'est traduit en hongrie en souvenir aux
tchèques république en thaïlande même
chez les tailles on aime bien la taille
de ce plan amoureux ça vous a aidé cette
notoriété
je crois que j'ai jamais eu de gros
soucis avec ray 1 vous en avez eu
beaucoup quand même
oui non mais j'espère en avoir encore
sous le mal qu'on vous souhaite
quel a été le meilleur moment de cette
époque là moi je vis pas dans la
nostalgie ou du temps je pense que je
suis plus construit aujourd'hui j'ai eu
un il ya un côté ou plus on devient
je pense qu'on fait les vrais choix et
c'est sur des choix de conviction
qu'elle était le pire moment de l'époque
celle là serait fâcheux c'est quoi
mauvaise rencontre au mauvais moment
ouais avec qui voilà vous devinez sonia
c'était c'est pas ce qui m'est arrivé il
ya deux mondes qui doivent pas se
croiser accrue donc aujourd'hui êtes pas
nostalgique de cette époque
non pas du tout je suis bien aujourd'hui
mais je suis bien demain mois sur la
construction je garde ça pas d'intérêt
ce qui est important c'est ce qu'on vit
et si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas pareil je me serais
arrêté avant j'ai pris ça trop comme un
jeu ouais je me suis éclatée j'en étais
mort de rire donc je suis parti dans une
spirale
parce que l'argent à un moment il y en a
assez ouais et je suis passé c'est le
jeu qui m'amusait c'était la connerie
mais l'humain m'intéresse moi j'aimais
mon grand défaut les ça vous aurait
évité les deux ans de taule oui puis
d'être un mauvais père ouais ne pas être
là pour mes enfants
si j'ai un échec c'est celui là mais mon
fils je n'ai pas vu grandir il est
il a grandi à new york machy avec le
mannequin de shefford
elle est née je rentrais en prison ouais
y'a que tess donc voit effectivement
aujourd'hui on a un peu plus vous
rattraper le jour vous allez mourir
qu'elle voulait qu'on écrive sur votre
tombe
christophe que la folie continue
merci c'est très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sans merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux